جرن منجر
من
ورزق
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله اما بعد يقول
الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى في رياضه
في باب التوبه وعن ابي سعيد سعد بن س ابن
مالك بن سنان الخدري
رضي الله عنه ان نبي الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال
الحافظ النبوي رحمه الله
سعيد سعد بن مالك ابن سنان الخدري رضي
الله عنه
ابو سعيد الخدري رضي الله عنه
حديث
سعد بن مالك ابن سينان رضي الله عنه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم كان في من كان
قبلكم
رجل قتل
نفسا
فسال عن اعلم اهل الارض
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏And so
he want to ask
and he asked for upon desiring to repent
he asked the people about the
knowledgeable
of
him about his repentance how could go
about repenting etب
‏was
to a
monk person who kinds himself away and
is more concern with worship not
traditionally concerned with knowledge
they are kind of the laborers if
you will and so
‏in الله سبحانه وتالى
‏before and will
that is a maunding
to think you can
accidentally
geter to
that you can stumble your way into the
gra of
high position in parad doesn't work that
‏if have to
otheray
and other will
onlyingefat
and those brief will outweigh
ابو ذر رضي الله عنه
انما يخشى الله من عباده العلماء
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏was
question was tok when he was asked about
the knowledable
because
people usually and the lay folks do not
usually know the differ they can't tell
the differ between a person of knowledge
‏How can you that un you would
architect the skilled of any knowledge
any trade. ‏You wouldn't know this
unless you were a member of that trade
and a knowledgeable person. Which is why
the ageold question what is a scholar?
Who is a scholar? That's the question.
Who is a scholar? A scholar is whom
other scholars deem as a scholar.
And so he was directed to a monk.
انه قتل 99 نفسا لاحظوا لفظ النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
يذكر القصه
بالغيبه
ما يقول
اني قتلت 99 نفسا مع انه هذا الذي قاله
صاحب القول لكن هو قاله بالغيبه لماذا؟
لان الكلام لا يليق
ان يكون منسوبا الى النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم او المتكلم
ففي هذه الاحوال
العرب يكنون كلامهم بهذه الطريقه يعني
لطيفه جميله جدا يقول انه قتل 99 نفسا فهل
له من توبه؟
فقال لا
قال لا كيف التو 99 نفسا عظم هذا
اكثر مما عظم رحمه الله وهذا هو الجهل هذا
هو الجهل بعينه تعظيم الماده على خالق
الماده
99 نفسا عقله لم يتحمل وقلبه
ان الله تعالى
هو الرحمن الرحيم
فقتله
فكمل به 100able
‏onilling
99 people murdered 99 souls is any
chance for him to repent and accept
repentance
this
man said no
how could youent 99 people
حم
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
anytionut
mery
mery could this
manilled
even human being we
‏even numbers and having everything
putting putting the dotting our eyes and
crossing our tees. ‏guy was a perist he
made it being that there's no chance for
him
and so we see the extreme
violence the extreme me the huge
corruption and misch that comes
inadvertently as a byproduct of
ignorance
ignorance is at the root of all human in
this life
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين